so if you have a question for Dr wallik
and you'd like to join us live again go
to daily withth do
zoom.com and you'll be able to join us
here live I just want to welcome
everybody if you were invited by
somebody specific don't forget to get
back with them and tell them thank you
for inviting you to this program this is
a special honor that we have to be able
to jump on here with Dr Wall as he takes
time to
continue continue the message of
Hope is this is part of his schedule
this is what he does every day several
times a day and the fact that he
includes Us in it um I feel greatly
honored and as the hostess of this
program I am honored to be the hostess
of daily with Doc Zoo today so anyways
my name is Becca Dukes and I want to
say The Food Supplies around the world
are null and void of the nutrition that
we need in order to do more than just
survive folks I don't know about you or
where you're at in your health Journey
right now but I was not surviving in
fact there were days where I was hoping
I would make it through the day and when
I started giving my body the nutrition
that it needed I got my life back and
started to thrive not just barely
survive and the information that is
going to be shared today is going to be
very beneficial in helping you to do the
same so as we are going through we do
have a special guest that we are waiting
for um in addition to of course Dr wck
being a special guest but Dr wallik you
you have been a lifetime learner you
have been feeding into the lives of so
many people around the
world and it doesn't matter who they
are you love
people you love to lift people up and
give them hope because you
yourself being somebody that nobody
wanted to be around as a child found
that and now you're able to share it
with others so I just want to thank you
well I and
folks I don't care if it offends you or
not I'm praising God that God used Dr
wallik to make such an
impact and have him go through
everything that he has gone through to
be able to share his story today so Dr
wck well thank you Becca and your team
for the kind introduction and your
presence and everything you do and the
consistency of everything you do and
again today we're hoping and praying
that um Theo gets here because he was to
be the featured guest but we'll start
out with his story um some years ago of
course I I I'm only uh what 5 foot six I
think when I'm Standing
Tall 5 foot two when I'm slouching okay
and it's one of those things where um
I'm I'm not a basketball player because
I'm to shark with Theo
um I met him his uh Pastor actually
brought him to us because he had lost
his position with the Atlanta Hawks he
had been playing with them after he
graduated college and um a basketball of
course Atlanta Hawks and he had bone to
bone arthritis and both his leg now he's
24 years old he had bone to bone
arthritis and both his knees he had the
Carly slipping off his hips he had a
fracture in his shooting arm wrist his
right wrist and so he lost his contract
well one year into his three-year
contract with the Atlanta Hawks that's
like a $30 million contract because he
he's a shooter okay he was good a
Defender he was good and his Pastor
brought him to me and says you know I
understand you're working with athletes
boxers and people in basketball and
football and stuff what about basketball
I said well let's talk to Theo so he
brought Theo over and sure enough I said
well yes sir we can do something for you
and what I did was I took our we already
knew about the 90 essential nutrients
we're already going that direction the
90 cents nutrients 60 minerals 16
vitamins 12 amino acids Three fatty
acids which are the basic necessities of
all human beings especially those doing
physical stress including
sports but because he had all this stuff
going on with all his cartilage and
connection Ive tissue and dis and um all
this kind of stuff um we came up with a
collagen product we called gluc gel okay
we added the glucogel collagen product
to the healthy Bone and Joint pack or
the Healthy Start pack and called it the
healthy Bone and Joint pack and and
brought it to Theo got him taking it two
three times a day and in six months time
he gets another position with
professional basketball okay make long
story short he played for 11 more
years made $100 million and he buys with
that money he buys this facility which
is a rehab facility on many many acres
of land in um Georgia and he uses it to
help disabled kids that are emotionally
disabled psychologically disabled and
physically disabled and he does that for
the community I just I thought that was
so great for him to do that and of
course if you look look at the cans of
rebound if you look at the canister of
the powder rebound I don't think it's on
the box of the sticks but on the on the
canisters rebound there's a picture of
Theo in the cans of rebound there's a
picture of Theo and of course I think it
was probably a year or two into it where
he became famous again he was a shooter
he was just
Unstoppable and so he came up with his
for string for
him rebound
uh to compete with Red Bull and it's
really you know the the um story
of of
um what you say energy drinks for
athletes is kind of a sad story Red Bull
became you know the primary one I mean
it was the big guy okay it still is the
biggest one I think but couple of months
ago guy of the name of dietrix uh
Ms who is one of the co-founders of Red
Bull died at age 78 and he'd been
bragging for years where he'd been
drinking 20 25 cans of Red Bull a day
okay for over 20 years and he dies at 78
and um this is really a terrible story
when you think about it okay and Red
Bull only has one mineral in it only has
the mineral magnesium in it and then you
go back to
1973 when
Bruce Lee died of a heart attack he was
only 32 years old and he was considered
the fitness Guru he was considered the
fitness athlete of of every in every
country in the world he was invited to
speak at graduations and colleges and
speak to professional teams and Olympic
teams all over the world and he dies of
a heart attack at age 32 because he only
supplemented with one mineral magnesium
because doctors convinced him don't
waste your money on vitamins and
minerals just take you know just eat
well you get everything you need and
unfortunately he believed the doctors
okay instead of us and he died at age of
32 of a heart attack terrible terrible
story okay a good story turned terrible
but anyway um Theo has done such a great
job he continues to be a community
person he continues to um uh go around
the world and share his story and you
know bring young athletes along and make
sure that they know his story so they
can take the 90 cents of nutrients and
do the rebound and so
forth we can't thank Theo enough for
this okay because there's literally I
would say there's tens of
thousands of
people every hour every day every week
every month around the world who use our
program with the rebound for strink and
the healthy Bone and Joint pack
for their bones and joints okay because
of theost stor and he is
um what um Bruce Lee should have been
because the has been doing this with us
I don't know exactly I was you know I
was going to get the exact time from
Theo but it's like 25 years or more okay
25 years or more Theo's been with us
bringing all this information to people
okay and saving kids
um having kids you know who grew up in
very what should I say
um districts of very bad very bad places
they're living to get into college
because they they gain skills and
strength because of our our um Sports
diet our healthy Bone and Joint pack and
also our rebound and going on to play
basketball to play football to wrestle
like I did
to get into boxing like my father did
and get into all these Sports track and
weightlifting and and so forth because
of our rebound so very very proud of
that and apologize because you know we
thought the was going to be here and
maybe he got the times mixed up because
he's on the East
Coast we'll see but any rate now we do
have
a a set a three CD set that I want
everybody that has somebody in their
family who exercises who somebody in
their family who works in some place
where they do a lot of physical labor
for somebody who's going to school
junior high high school um grade school
college okay they're in the military all
right I retire as lieutenant colonel in
the Air Force so I know about the
military and so CD number one is dead
athletes don't lie talks about a lot of
famous athletes died in their 20s and
30s because they weren't taking the 90
cents of nutrients and then the second C
there he is oh is the on now Theo is I
think he's on yeah Theo is that to
you ask to
unmute okay I'll keep going until he
unmutes okay so okay so the second CD is
exercise without supplementation is
suicide okay because when you exercise
you're not just losing water in your
sweat you're losing nutrients and if
you're just drinking water to rehydrate
you're not going to make it that's why
there's so many athletes in their 20s
and 30s and 40s that die of what's
called hypertrophy chopy heart disease
which in little infants is called camid
death syndrome okay we found out the
cause R cure well we can't say cure we
found out the cause prevention of it in
these infants and in athletes when they
get diagnosed if they don't just die on
the court or in the field or in the
shower but they do have a heart attack
we can rehab them okay within 90 cent of
nutrients and these what we call the
secret sauces for this particular
deficiency the third CD in is set is
what kills billionaires what kills
billionaires these three CDs everybody
should get this CD set and listen to it
if give it is gifts to their family
because even if they're not going to be
professional
athletes okay even if they're just going
exercise they walked around the block
they need this information because
exercise without supplementation is
suicide okay now did we were we able to
get Theo
on he is here with us Dr W we're working
on sound Theo if you could try unmuting
again let's
see if we still have an
echo hello
yeah I'm about to go outside um yeah I
was in the gym
so all right we have Theo Ratliff in the
house with us thank you so much Theo for
joining us here on daily with doc Dr
well was just giving an introduction of
um your story and how the two of you met
and I'm so excited to have both of you
here with us today and when you are
positioned where you can turn your
camera on I'd like to have both of you
up here on the screen so that we can see
you both in a
conversation yeah because I I need some
dates from Theo Theo you
there yeah hold on one
second he's getting situated Dr Wall
okay yeah I'm walking to my car right
now okay all right fantastic okay
because I'm G to find out exactly when
your pastor put us together okay I want
to know how many years ago it was okay
and um um what professional teams you
played for and so forth that kind of
stuff okay and okay tell me when you're
ready and it's one of those great
stories that was a story that it was the
never- Ending Story because we always
added to it and Theo just kept on going
and adding to it and so it's one of
those great stories that needs to be
told over and over and over because
there's so many people
who um wind up with injuries
unnecessarily who get injuries and and
don't get proper treatment unnecessarily
there's people who die prematurely
unnecessarily okay because they don't
get the
information and again this three CD set
is actually put together a Theo story
dead athletes don't lie exercise
cementation of suicide and what kills
billionaires and you have to appreciate
that just drinking water after you
exercise rehydrate is suicidal because
sweat is not just water sweat contains
all the the nutrients floating around in
your blood and you're sweating them out
I mean you're exercising heavily twice a
day and then you know playing um on
teams and that kind of stuff hey Doc
look up hello we're good okay there's
SEO okay
let's see here when did we get together
what year was that when you when the
pass 20
2002 2002 so everything was going a ride
for me I know it was going good yeah
everything was going going great until
it
wasn't okay and then the brought 20 20
years ago 21 years ago yeah so 2002 um I
met Phil Oliver and Mike Glenn who you
guys might know that's a part of the uh
distribution team uh here in
Atlanta um after I had just got traded
after making All-Star Game breaking my
wrist and um and also during that summer
after I had recovered from the wrist
injury I just took a routine jump and I
end up tearing my lab room in my hip so
everything was just falling apart and um
I met those guys they they spoke to me
about um have I ever heard of mineral
deficiencies I'm like what is that I
have no no clue what that is and so they
was like man I need need to introduce
you to a Dr Joel
wallet down I need to introduce you to a
do Joe wall who has basically helped
to um helped to
treat the I mean we we call it the pig
pack plus before the off Riders and pigs
and different things of that nature and
all these different treatments that he's
done through his veterinarian medicine
and he's tooken into his practice
of being a doctor through human human
medicine so uh through human um uh using
minerals through for the human body to
heal different things of the same
diseases that plague the animals
so I was kind of skeptical at first and
it kind of sounded
crazy when you talk about you know the
human in the mix um you know especially
with me being young but as I did my due
diligence and and understood exactly
where he was coming from when he's
talked about You're Not Gon to give an
animal a $100 pill in order to
supplement some of the disease and
injuries that he that he has you're
going to find a nutritional way which is
a lot cheaper to be able to
help um cure certain things in animals
so with that said he when he formulated
American Longevity at first he created
that platform to be able to utilize it
with you know with with their human
human body so um I've been taking the
product like I said now 20 something
years um going strong still going strong
um just had some a few minutes ago right
before the workout with the boys so so
um it's something that I do on a daily
basis to just maintain my health even
after playing 16 years in the NBA so um
it's it's a great product um we love Dr
de I mean he's like I say he's been a
savior for me because I I say in in 2001
after I did the labor room tear um and
trying to recover um the problem was I
wasn't
healing and I thought I was gonna have
to retire so as I got on the nutrients
and my body start building back I got
stronger stronger and stronger as I was
with the uh Atlanta Hawks and I end up
winning uh two more two two defensive uh
black shot
championships um led the league in Black
shot for two
years for for two years uh two years in
a row um after that um so and then
signed a nice big contract which you
know I love and appreciate you doc
we're just telling your stories good
enough we appreciate your story I have
to I have to ask you a question see let
me interrupt here let me ask you a
question go ahead okay um when it comes
to um your healing story um you did
something with with some of your money
you you bought this
facility uh what would you call it is it
a rehab center or a training center what
is it
you oh I have a no I have an activity
center that
I through the
foundation Foundation yeah what
Foundation Community Center back home in
Demopolis okay and what's your
foundation with different projects and
you know people can come in play
basketball we have uh a computer center
where the adults can learn how to work
computers kids everybody as a as a whole
ENC compress the whole community
to come in so how long how long have you
been running that facilities there for
the community that facility been in
existence for at least 15 years 15 years
okay so it's very thoughtful of you to
spend you know a lot of people just take
the money and run the fact that you
invested in your community you invested
in your family you invested in uh the
state um we're really so very very proud
of you that you did such a great job uh
in healing yourself okay and of course
we're glad we were able to contribute to
that and you stayed away from all the
bad stuff you didn't do street drugs and
you didn't you know do alcohol and all
that kind of stuff you did nutrition so
we're very very proud of you and thank
you thank you thank you for taking care
of the community with your facility we
really are so proud of you for that a
great product came out of this as well
because when when I came back which
helped me you know get those block shot
titles and second team Defensive Player
of the Year and all those different
accolades that I got through the NBA was
that good old rebound Doc is holding the
cans up right now and also the the call
I call it the magic stick the magic
stick there you
go yes you can run you can take it
anywhere you want with you put it in
about eight ounces of water and you're
good to go your energy is high and all
things are
well there you go it's one of those
things where you know you created entire
what should I say community okay because
the the previous energy drinks were
primarily sugar and caffeine our our
rebound has 75 minerals in it and 25
vitamins amino acids in it has like um I
don't know 25% of the sugar and 25% of
the caffeine that Red Bull has in it and
Red Bull only has one mineral in it it
only has magnesium in it we have 75
minerals in rebound so we're very very
proud of you and of course at home I
drink the cans but I pop the tops and at
night put them in the refrigerator so
they're flat in the morning all the
carbonation gone but when I get in an
airplane like you say I'm going out to
dinner some at night I take the sticks
with me U and tear the top off and put
them in a little bottle of water and
drink
them and so I go through at least two
full doses of the rebound a day and only
weigh 142
pounds
you lost
weight yeah I did lose a little bit of
weight I I gotten up to about 160 was my
high point I got up to about 160 and um
and so but that's because I was I was
eating four or five meals a day and I'm
back down to each just eating two two
nice meals a day and having at lunch
I'll have uh some of our triple treat
chocolate and our some cheese sticks
along with the rebound and that's my
lunch but I'll have two big uh a
breakfast and a big dinner time okay I
like my steaks I like my eggs and I like
I like all that stuff and we can't thank
you enough um because you've been such a
good example to Young athletes coming
along Theo um you didn't do drugs you
didn't do abuse alcohol and so we're so
very very proud of you for all the
things you've done uh for uh kids for
America for Humanity in the world so
we're very proud of you for all you've
done
yeah doc I try try to school them every
time I get a
chance well so let's School some people
not just athletes because I've got a
question here on YouTube wanting to know
if rebound is just for
athletes oh of course of course not I
mean anytime you need a pick me up
energy wise and also it has the minerals
in it as well so that that was one of
the main purposes uh for Doc creating it
is so I can replenish minerals or you
can replenish minerals as you work out
or if you just need a boost and and you
need some some good nutrition it's
better than grabbing you know the
gatoray and different things that nature
that gives you nothing but like you said
sugar and water there you go so I have a
couple questions Theo you were breaking
bones tearing
tendons ligaments Dr mentioned uh the
hip capsule that's painful I've torn a
hips capsule and he said that yours was
slipping off something like that and I
wasn't an
athlete so you had put your body through
a
lot as a
team and you were experiencing that H
you started feeling all of these effects
at how
old um well unbeknown to me it was it
was going on because I mean when you're
young you just you just playing through
stuff but you know as I started going
into the NBA they started telling me I
had degenerative tissues and knes and
different things and they just from the
long term of being from playing from
elementary all the way through through
college um but they still drafted me
anyway so they they felt I I could I
could last but I would probably start
suffering some injuries you know right
around that field six year and it
happened just like they said it would
and my body started falling apart so
um so yes it was uh yeah it was it was a
tough road and it it started early on um
you know even through early as College
college
days so what I take from this Theo is
you don't wait until you're starting to
feel the negative effects of working
your body definitely don't worry because
like I say I had what I had was early it
would be I was like I was an older man
you know I I was developing osteoporosis
lack of you know the vitamin D to
minimal I mean and you know with with
what with the minerals brought with I
with the oo effect and magnesium it
brought those that ability to be able to
to get the calcium up the vitamin D up
and all those things that help you know
strengthen my bones at the same time you
had the the uh gelatin the gluco gel and
everything helping it clo clo uh coat
the joints um to rebuild carage and
different things of that nature that
helped me like I said continue to play
10 more years in the NBA it was all
Built For You
Theo well he he like pushed you to put
something together Dr
wallik but what has come of this
formulation to help Theo can now help
anybody and everybody I know it helped
me I had the jgen of bone and dis
disease 30 years old the the neurologist
that was looking at my MRI walked in and
walked back out because he thought he
was coming to see somebody 65 to 70
years old in poor health oh wow so folks
I mean
Theo if you don't believe my story here
we have
Theo that has taken the
nutrients and it has made such an
impactful
I mean it gave him his life back it gave
him his career back allowed him to be
able to continue the career that he
loved for many many years making enough
money to make an even larger impact in
his
community where he lives plus be an
example
folks of it's not too
late and for us as parents and
grandparents and even kids that are
listening to this if you're
active or I'm going to say for me I was
living in Phoenix I did a lot of
sweating of course on the farm I did a
lot of stuff but I was not an
athlete you take the nutrients all the
time starting as early as absolutely
possible to give your body what it needs
so that it can Thrive from the beginning
and keep on
going now Theo you're no longer an
athlete are you still taking the
nutrients Oh Yes actually you are still
an athlete I mean you're working out
with your kids and there you go he's got
them right
there got
muted work out with the kids um like I
said it's it's something that you know
is a part of
me like I try to take it every time
every time I get a chance uh every day
every day of the week if I can started
when I was nine when I was nine years
old was when I started at least four
times a week for
sure yeah it's it's part of a lifestyle
folks yeah you're investing into your
own
Wellness right and I think there is
nothing better yep and like doc said um
when he when he when they talked about
the number pills like the the gelatin
pills and the EFA pills it was like it
it's it's natural so it's not like
you're taking pharmaceutical drugs so
don't be alarmed you have to take six
pills that's always the biggest hurdle
for people when I talk to them about it
like six bills no I'm not taking six
pills because it's natural to just take
one two pharmaceutical drugs and then
you know you you get the effects of
whatever it is but with this it's it's
natural so whatever it is that you put
into your body it absorbs in your body
it's not going to cause any side effects
or different things of that nature which
is always you know a great thing so I
think you made a good point to you that
um the medications deal with the
symptoms and don't get to the basic root
cause of the problem where these
nutrients get to the basic root cause of
the problem which is a totally different
approach so thank you for pointing that
out well and think about it we're using
food as medicine
right are you g to feel get filled up
and fortify your body with is one little
pill that chemically
Alters the body and its response to
pain no you're not so folks when doc doc
goes through he takes he takes a lot
I've seen it I don't take that much and
I still had great results and I still
feel
great and you can
too so we invite you to give Dr wallx
formulas 90 days I mean you you're gonna
start feeling the difference don't stop
oh don't stop keep going right Theo is
consistency that's
it
yeah I'm gonna take this for at least 10
years after I die I'm going to make sure
they put a 10e supply these nutrients
into my coffin when I
die do you want it in the bottle
or just pour it
on no just you know you know just in the
containers I don't want the ants to get
any of
it h Dr
W well so
Theo what do you see in your
future what other big plans do you have
that you're now able to do
whether it's because of your NBA career
because of what you have found in
youngevity well mainly these these guys
right here hi guys oh look at
that yeah so just uh continue to be be
Daddy
coach and try to you know help them
understand what proper nutrition is and
what it can do for them as well so I can
get them to take it every now and
then well that's that's one of God's
greatest um what should I say paths is
to do good things for the next
generation and your fellow people in
your generation we cannot thank you
enough for sharing all that you've done
uh because you have been a light in the
darkness because you stuck with it you
are still doing it and you know you're
still out there being physical and how
old are you
now I'm about to turn 50 next week
you're gonna turn 50 the big
five five all right well
congratulations it's a
blessing yes happy early birthday happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you so
we'll be the first ones to sing you
happy birthday Theo and I know you and
the kids are out and you're busy taking
some time out to join us here we just
greatly appreciate you and thank you for
for all that you've done I know doc
talks about you all the time yes I
appreciate you're one of guys's greatest
angels we love you for it y thank you
back so all right all
right go get some of that good
rebound get the minerals in your life
change
life that's right that's right awesome
well thank you so much Theo we
appreciate you you've been such an
inspiration to many including Dr wck and
Theo story have a bless this book yeah
the wall Revolution your story is in
this book there's a 75 year journey and
there's all these great stories in there
and Theo's story is one of them an
impossibility just based on nutrition
and of course we cannot thank feel
enough um for you know being uh this
story in this book The Wall Revolution
now there's there you go there's dozens
of stories in there okay these are some
of my major successes we couldn't get
all
600 in there okay we do have dozens of
major stories in here and Theo story is
one of them because he was a mess okay
there is no way he was going to come
back and play professional basketball
with bone arthritis his knees they
wanted to give him double knee
replacement the cartly was slipping off
his hips they want to give him double
hip replacement he fractured his
shooting wrist um oken's right hand and
you know nobody comes back from that
well he did because he gave up all the
bad stuff which he wasn't doing much of
but he did take all the good stuff
Faithfully he recovered very quickly he
came back got a new contract and played
for 11 more years and then of course he
contributed to his community and the
surrounding community and Humanity by
getting this facility and we cannot
praise him enough for
that yeah I think it's awesome as I'm
going through looking at the comments um
here on out on YouTube uh we have
sportis says that Theo was the fastest
hardest working big man in the league
when he was at the Sixers just awesome
and then we have the captain says Theo's
maybe the best shop blocker ever so
there's a lot of people that remember
what he has done in the MBA and all of
his successes and Dr wellik you are part
of that and I'm so very excited that we
are able to be able to present him to to
our community also so folks if you are
watching and you know somebody who has
kids that are active in
sports if you know somebody that is
active themselves in sports please share
this program with
them be part of what keeps them from
having all of this degeneration that
trust me is very
painful you've heard the
message it's your obligation to share it
just to help somebody else not suffer
or to stop the suffering now we cannot
guarantee that our and we cannot say
that our products diagnose prevent cure
any diseases but folks your body was
designed to continually be
recreating and
growing and if you've got the raw
ingredients that it needs to create
healthy
cells you're going to have healthier
cells I mean it's like the liver Dr Wall
people can have therosis of the liver
stage four get on the nutrition take out
the bad foods decontaminate their
insides with nutrients by flooding the
bodies with nutrients and the liver can
come back yeah the liver has enormous
capacity to heal
itself and so so do muscle and the
connective tissue the skin all of these
things that based on what we put into
our
bodies the
outcome can be positive or
negative and we are empowered to play a
big part in that and Dr wallik your
formulas your research that went into
them has been so impactful in so many
lives that that I just can't thank you
enough for all that you have done I know
we have just a few more minutes I want
to make sure that everybody gets back
with the person that shared this program
with them thank them if there's nobody
to thank feel free to go to daily withth
do.com we do have a contact us there if
we I know we didn't get to many
questions today I'm going to try to get
to a
couple but use that contact us send us
your questions and if you have never
spoken to anybody about youngevity
before anybody about Dr wallik feel free
to contact my call team at 855
3377 but again that is for people who
have not already been in communication
with somebody about Dr wck and do and
the youngevity products so Dr wck let's
go to um hand up and and and I know that
the order is not right
because the co-hosts when they have
their hands up it doesn't come in the
right order but
Phyllis go ahead and unmute yourself and
come on I know you had a question for a
client that we were talking about before
the show so your hand was up
first uh yes doc I've got a question for
Helen she's not on the zoom she's 80
years years young retired military 5
foot4 150 pounds no medication now you
have already advised her on a few things
you've talked to her a couple of times
about
Ms sciatica in tonius and she
religiously avoids the bad foods and she
is a vegetarian but she's eating eggs
and as much healthy fat as she can and I
think this is hard to believe she may
take more product than you do she
probably takes several servings of the
brain and heart pack copious other
products so here's her question her legs
are uh below the knee are chronically
slightly swollen with tight muscles in
her calves recently one leg is a little
more swollen feels warm and red up to
the knee um got a brown patch near her
ankle with blistery skin she's been
putting colloidal silver on it which
seems to help uh what are your thoughts
on that uh red swollen
leg well she needs to add two things for
program number one the ultimate daily
classic tablets three words ultimate
daily classic tablets that'll Supply
greater blood flow okay and blood flow
support to all areas of the body
including the ankles and the feet and
the legs and the knees and the hips and
and the back and so forth okay and the
brain and then also if there's any blood
pressure issues going on there it'll
support healthy blood pressure if she's
on any blood pressure medication don't
pull turkey off of that but as the blood
pressure improves she can slowly reduce
the blood pressure medication based on
the numbers and
then we do have if she has pain uh
anywhere we do have the hemp effect
soothe okay put a couple of spritzes of
that wh she has the pain and it'll give
her about four to six hours of pain
relief and um I love it okay because
still do a lot of exercise and this that
and the other walking and that kind of
stuff and
so every once in while I'll pull
something and I use that soothe okay
it's called hemp FX and it's it's legal
and um you know I buy six of those tubes
at a time and when I get down to the
last tube I'll buy six more tubes you
know six tubes will last me about a year
okay for pain relief all right swelling
swelling relief
anti-inflammatory and then um let's see
here I think uh she's covering it um
with what she's doing but don't forget
that i' also throw in the MSM if she
doesn't is not taking the MSM she needs
the MSM at her body weight she could
take three three times a day it'll be
two bottles a month of MSM big bottles
and they will support and promote
maintenance repair of carage ligaments
tendons connective tissue disc between a
vertebra bone R Bon itself the
skin uh re walls anything made out of
collagen and connected tissue will be
benefited by the
MSM okay perfect thank you so much okay
well God bless you and you know give us
a call every a couple weeks and let us
know how she's doing sure will thank you
okay all right thank you Phyllis and
let's go right over to Gloria Gloria had
go ahead and unmute if you would you're
on live with Dr wallik hi Gloria what's
up
Gloria can you unmute yes there you go
and let me start the video um my
question I'm sorry I have LXI terrible
allergies here in the Napa Valley
um my question is about my
cholesterol a year and a half ago I was
283 and two weeks ago went up to
309 I am glutenfree I don't eat junk
don't drink junk the only thing I'm
doing different is having the three eggs
every morning as your
advised and my smoothies I add protein
and a lot of fruit I love fruit so I put
it in my smoothies and the protein to
supplement because I lost five pounds
and I want to get them back because I'm
116 yeah so I I'm the opposite so okay
well let's stop there let's stop there
for a minute okay cholesterol
cholesterol is not a bad thing
cholesterol does not block arteries that
was a
misrepresentation by doctors a hundred
years ago they missed it by a million
miles cholesterol does not cause blocked
arteries fried foods and salad dressings
and cooking oils is what causes blocked
arteries um cholesterol makes up 25% of
your brain weight normal brain weight as
the white matter of the brain okay um
the um cholesterol makes up 25% of your
spinal cord weight
okay it's called milin the white matter
of the brain it's white matter of the
brain and white matter of the spinal
cord are 100%
cholesterol
okay and so um to have your blood
cholesterol up above 100 is not a bad
thing you just need to not be frying
anything uh you know no Fried Chicken no
fried fish no fried potatoes no fried
vegetables no fried eggs nothing fried
okay I don't okay good but um yeah so do
not take cholesterol luring drugs okay
cholesterol Ling drugs will cause you to
really be in trouble you'll wind up
getting Alzheimer's disease you wind up
with Ms you wind up
with those kind of things um
so um also there's a new one out um uh
FTD frontal temporal dementia which is
kind of a Alzheimer's disease which
deals with the front and the temporal
parts of the brain and the whole back
half of the brain is normal and see
doctors can't figure that one out well
that's all because where the blood
supply is and so forth and you know
these are people who are taking statin
drugs are avoiding
cholesterol and that's why they're
losing their memory on the front part of
the brain and the temporal the size of
the brain because you know there's a lot
of cholesterol as as part of the my
white matter of the Rin
you hear oh yeah they did an MRI um
magnetic resonance imaging and they say
I have um I I have um I'm losing the
white matter my brain I've got
demonization well that means you're
losing the cholesterol in your brain
because you've been following the
doctor's advice on diet and
drugs and they're getting it all wrong
okay I know she wants me to take do
Statin and I say no I don't take any
medication I exercise I run I swim I do
everything what am I doing wrong that my
cholesterol went up that's my only
question okay well that means you're
sexy because cholesterol makes up 95% of
female hormon so if your cholesterol is
that high I'm beyond that I'm 77 I'm
beyond that
you're 77 I'm be beyond that I I just
want not to be a my kids
a we want we want you to get to be
130 as long as my brain works fine and
then my body functions so so I shouldn't
worry that my my um LDL is
198 and my um triglyceride is
99 and what else oh the A1C is 55 5.5
okay good now how's your
memory it's it's good it's not as good
as it used to be but it's it's yeah okay
how many how many times you wake up at
night to urinate once three times five
times once for sure sometimes once in a
while I sleep my eight hours without
waking up okay good what about um um has
your voice changed
any no just now with the allergies that
I
got my voice is better today today I
couldn't
speak okay um do you have any ring in
your ears any tentis ring in your ears
any
balance once in the Blue
Moon okay every once in a while all
right yeah okay well keep going like
you're going you're getting more good
things than bad things and so let's go
there call us every week or every two
weeks and you know keep in touch and
we'll kind of walk you through this but
you know you can have osteoprosis of the
skull squeezing the 12 pairs of cranial
nerves squeezing and spinal cord causing
a lot of this kind of stuff but um uh if
you're taking all these nutrients this
should uh all be good okay so
okay all right thank thank you Gloria
and Dr wallik real quick we've got a
female she's 47 years old 5 foot three
175 pounds going through hot flashes
hormonal IM
balances those are the only conditions
that she's experiencing no blood
pressure issues no blood sugar issues
what would you recommend for her okay to
170 pounds want her to give up all the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils no glutens no wheat no bar
ey oats no sugar no carbonat drinks no
buckwheat even the carbonat water's got
to go because it neutralizes stomach
acid so you can't absorb minerals and
digest food and then I wanted to have
two healthy brain and heart pure month
two healthy brand and heart passion
month full everything twice a day she
weighs 170 pounds right okay then want
to have two bottles a month of the MSM
take three of breakfast lunch dinner
time and they're going to support and
promote main repair of cart Leisure
ligaments tons connective tissue disc
between vertebra bone Mak bone sell skin
artery walles and all that kind of stuff
and then because she's having hot
flashes I wanted to get our Zera fem I
wanted to take three of those twice a
day um and that will give her ovaries
what they need to make hormones balance
that out so she's not having those
problems which are probably hormonally
um
related
um but she doesn't need to eat at 170
pounds um two to three eggs twice a day
with soft joles not hardboiled not fried
and let's see here uh I also wanted to
have at lunchtime one or two of our chil
i26 tablets they taste like vanilla ice
cream okay even little kids like them
and it'll say right on the label
provides 25% of the daily requirement of
cholesterol you require cholesterol
cholesterol makes up 95% of the weight
of female hormones 95% of the weight of
male hormones 25% of your brain and 25%
of your spinal cord any Doctor Who says
to stay away from cholesterol should
have their licenses suspended or even
taken
away all right thank you so much for
that Dr wallik and and we greatly
greatly appreciate you I know you need
to get on to your next program thank you
so much folks you heard it cholesterol
is not our enemy cholesterol is required
and is what's needed
95% of our
hormones estrogen testosterone 25% of
our brain weight is
cholesterol
if you take that
away it's only makes it's like common
sense you you take away the cholesterol
that the brain needs what's going to
happen to the brain it's going to stop
functioning the way we want it to you
take cholesterol away and it's 95 I mean
it's needed for our hormones and hormone
balance and then you've got eggs that
have been demonized and we wonder why
everybody's going
crazy
okay that's those are my words Dr not Dr
Wallace but I just want to thank you all
for joining us here on daily with Doc if
I could get my co-hosts up with me I
would greatly appreciate it we have
Phyllis Anderson and Ruth Ellen Sanchez
Sher Browning Marilyn Perera and also we
have far Farhan with us so everybody it
takes a team it takes different skills
to be able to put a program like this
together to be able to build a business
and that's what we do we use what's
called Advanced team building in
building our businesses as certified
holistic health
coaches and youngevity
Associates the we use youngevity
products as
solutions to a problem that is prevalent
around the world around the world new
nutrient
deficiencies are impacting lives
impacting families impacting communities
they're impacting our world everyone and
fortunately we have a supply of those
plant derived minerals those prehistoric
minerals that will last thousands of
years that we want to make sure that we
share with people around the
world if you
have a heart for people if you want to
make an additional income stream if you
have skills that you want to put to use
as part of a team get back with the
person that shared this program with you
tell them hey you know I think I want
some more information about what it is
that I can do to help build
awareness of nutrient deficiencies how
they impact life and the solution to
restoring healthier communities around
the
world my name is Becca Dukes the hostess
of this program daily with Doc I am very
honored to have my co-hosts with me who
are here as support each and every day
for myself and those that contact us and
thank you thank you team
Rebeca for impacting my life yes ma'am
what am I
forgetting we are not going to be on my
uh Wednesday Thursday or Friday of this
week and we will see everybody next
week and Becca I'm not gonna forget I'm
taking a vacation folks she needs it
Rebecca needs break and we all love
working with Rebecca as much as she
loves us
well thank you so
much thank you thank you you're welcome
everyone out in YouTube world thank you
we will miss you too
sportist um and Rumble and Facebook and
all of those that are here with us live
on daily with Doc on daily with Doc live
Zoom no daily daily with.
zoom.com
um you can find all of our replays for
our past almost three years now that
include asoc live so I got to keep all
those words right on daily withth
do.com you'll also find a store there
that's for the people that have not
spoken to anybody about youngevity or Dr
wle feel free to use our store feel free
to use us as a resource to help spread
spr the news the message of hope that
there are things that we can do as
empowered individuals to help ourselves
and our families and our communities not
just survive but Thrive until next time
bye for now
[Music]
m
n
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]